while we covered a ton in our last two
battlefield 2042 videos there were still
some lingering community questions
around specialists
ai and the games maps dice did a
follow-up stream and an xbox extended
presentation that actually answered a
lot i'm gonna be honest i've been pretty
busy with e3
but i'm excited to talk about this stuff
now so let's dive in
we are heading quickly towards more
battlefield 2042 announcements in july
as well as alphas and betas so join us
by giving us the old thumbs up and
subscribing to the channel let's get to
it
specialists are where i think most
confusion came up in the comments we
know there will be tenant launch plus
another four confirmed to release across
four seasons
a lot of people wanted clarification if
they're a replacement for the old class
system
and the answer we now know is they are
not battlefield 2042
will still have assault recon engineer
and support
under those classes you will then get to
specialize by picking fully voiced
characters that come with a unique
gadget and trait it isn't as different
from previous battlefield games as it
first appeared in my opinion
many of the specialists unique traits
and gadgets look like things you would
have just selected before
such as casper the recon specialist has
a drone gadget and a motion sensor
the recon drone is basically the miv
from previous games and it can even fire
emp
darts which it always could a lot of
people didn't know that his motion
sensor trait is a moving version of the
previous ground sensors
or the throwable ball from bad company
the shield we saw deployed is another
iteration of one already in battlefield
4. now the shield could be specialist
specific or an open gadget and we'll get
to that in a bit
we've only seen a few specialists so far
and there could be some really cool ones
coming down the line so we're all about
it now one of the motivations dice
mentioned for the creation of
specialists was interesting
and i both get it and i also think
there's some things to consider here the
short version is the data pointed to
players largely choosing classes in
battlefield games based on the primary
weapon and not the gadget
so developers decided to unchain guns
from classes that means players can
choose a specialist gadget based on
their playstyle or team needs and also
pick any gun
let's speculate a little bit on just why
people ignore classes in favor of guns
and what i think wasn't said here
although it could have been considered
we just don't know
people usually pick guns because of two
main reasons the first is pretty simple
there's usually a meta and they don't
want to die a lot if one class has the
best gun
well it's a no-brainer if a map is a
vehicle map of course they're going to
take the class with a launcher so they
aren't helpless
the next more important thing to talk
about is the influence of an unlocked
tree on player behavior
many shooters not just battlefield tai
unlocks an experience
far too closely to just kills that gives
players way less of an incentive to play
objectives or do
anything except jumped on the smallest
map possible where they can make the
most kills get the most experience and
unlock the most attachments once they
have a gun fully unlocked it becomes
tedious to start over with another gun
because you're at a disadvantage not
having your weapon maxed out so players
often just think about guns
a more freeform unlocked tree like what
was in battlefield hardline for example
and awarding more points for playing
objectives than just kills could make
the old class system viable again
instead of needing these specialists the
concern is that the current system might
end up with some seriously overpowered
classes
people mention in the comments for
example that casper can see people
sneaking up on him on the minimap all
the
time so that plus an lmg or a top of
meta ar
might make them too overpowered versus
the same recon type in pass games who
would have had the situational awareness
but was limited in what weapons they
could carry to be fair that system has
been loosening for years
allowing any class to pick mid-tier
carbines or pdws
we love sandboxes so we're just gonna
have to see what happens i'd honestly
rather have the freedom and let things
break on occasion
than have things more controlled
circling back on reward systems there's
a chance here for battlefield 2042 to
follow in the footsteps of hardline a
game i still think didn't get enough
credit for what it did right it allowed
players to pretty much go play whatever
they wanted
and then go unlock just about anything
it's the ideal system
the good news is that in the stream they
clearly said you can unlock all
characters and vehicles at the same
time that really feels like either we're
getting a system similar to hardline or
it may have been referring to how modern
battle passes unlock all kinds of things
as you go
either way it sounds good battlefield in
particular though needs to award the
most xp for playing objectives and the
least for
just volume of kills there's a danger
that if it doesn't do this players are
just going to go to breakthrough mode
and ignore the massive conquest mode
that makes battlefield so special
then there are also challenges which far
too often in old battlefield titles
encourage
bad behaviors all challenges should
teach players how to play a specialist
or a class properly just like the gen 10
system did from titanfall
again we'll have to wait to see what
systems are in the game
so this is a good spot to talk about the
freedom of weapons and gear some of the
motivation behind the plus system of the
game that lets you swap attachments on
the fly was to avoid a legit classic
battlefield problem and devs are right
on here if you took the wrong loadout
into a match before your only option was
really just to redeploy and lose a
ticket in conquest mode the plus system
makes you more adaptable to situations
but in this stream they also talked
about its limits which is good for
example you can't make an smg suddenly
behave like a sniper rifle it sounds
like dice put consideration into what
attachments go with what guns
it also sounds like open gear meaning
gear that any specialist can use
is pretty extensive falk who's a medic
under support class can still take
anti-vehicle weapons and gadgets we also
got another burning question answered
here a lot of people wondered if the
wingsuit was tied specifically to
sundance or was an open gadget and the
answer is that it is tied to specialists
that seems like a hell of a lot of fun
but also
duck hunt anyone
another area that we got a lot of
questions over in the comments was about
ai matches
in earlier presentations it seemed like
ai bots were their own thing
but bots are actually very pervasive in
the game 128 player matches will start
with bots who then filter out as players
join in there's gonna be every
combination imaginable full ai matches
unit squad vs ai and mixed ai and player
pvp regions where people can't get full
matches will also be stacked with bots
vehicles are getting their own sub
engine in frostbite and boy is it time
ground vehicles always felt awkward to
me in battlefield games and the
frostbite engines struggled particularly
with fast moving ones
battlefield hardline's cars honestly
felt like this giant hand was always
pushing down on them like a child
playing with a toy car
better car physics will make for more
fun driving and a higher skill ceiling
for players we also learned a lot more
about the seats in cars giving
passengers more to do
this will include things like spotter
seats 360 degree turrets
anti-air abilities grenade launchers and
even a place to deploy mines on the go
maps and pacing oddly enough i think
this was my favorite part of the
presentation
some maps like hourglass are designed
for both fast and slow moments in the
new conquest mode you'll be frantically
capturing a sector one minute and then
grouping up and rolling out in convoys
the next
for large vehicle battles on your way to
the next sector this is very much like
how planetside 2 works and dam if my old
battlefield friend ryan and i haven't
said we need more planetside 2 in
battlefield for
years non-stop action and games can
honestly get tiresome and kind of boring
you need these prep phase moments
between battles to absorb what happened
and enjoy what's coming next dev says
specifically that they looked at gold
mode railway and sinai desert maps for
inspiration
if you want a reference point we also
got some insight into terms
the call-in tablet is what you use to
airdrop vehicles at your location we
still don't know if that's based on a
point system though or happens when you
capture a sector
the game is gonna launch with seven maps
which in past battlefield games i don't
think was enough and quickly got bored
with
consider you might play one or two of
these to death and betas so really
you're getting five or six
new ones but it feels different this
time because the maps are
huge and their purpose built for just
two modes at launch that's awesome and
exactly the right approach to
battlefield map design we now know these
maps will also have a lot of variation
between levolution and tornadoes which
take random pass
or sometimes won't even show up it's all
about variety and it feels like we're
gonna get it this time
there's also a lot of small details on
map locations but it's probably not
worth getting into until we can actually
show you so let's circle back on that in
another video
modes 2042 will start with two modes but
the more i think about it they aren't
super different from past battlefield
games just
more honed and that's probably a good
thing conquest is basically just
conquest ception the objectives you
capture to take a sector can be thought
of as just
mini conquest within conquest what seems
to be different here are the vast spaces
between sectors so capturing one means
the enemy team gets pushed really far
away and you get time to regroup
breakthrough the second launch mode is
just having players fight in a single
sector
so really just cramming more players
into places they would already be in
conquest what's to be seen here is if
sectors properly divide up 128 players
as advertised
if we get too many players in one
location then you'll wind up just
spawning and dying instantly which can
become kind of tedious
to be fair some of you love 64 player op
metro and this might be your
jam so not everything got answered in
these presentations and we still have
some lingering questions
going through these in no particular
order how does vehicle play work when
everybody has a launcher and how will
vehicles hope to survive with that much
ordinance being shot at them
when launchers were tied to just the
engineer class at least there was a
limit to how many might be out there
will the new conquest work if it's
basically just conquest points within
conquest points
i know it's designed to spread players
out but what happens if players don't
ever fully capture sectors what happens
if an entire team just decides to roll
as a unit does this mean even more
people need to stick around to defend
objectives when players typically don't
like to do that something that will
probably be a dea play but
how is hazard zone not a battle royale
in this stream it was described as a
high-stakes squad-based mode that builds
tension as you play
which sounds super battle royale we do
know now that you can bring specialist
loadouts and gadgets with you so maybe
less scavenging is involved
but the hazard zone title definitely
sounds like areas of the map getting cut
off i mean call of duty black ops cold
war tried dirty bomb
and it's not great so we're curious to
see what dice's takes gonna be it was
also dropped here that
dice la is working on something special
being shown at ea play so if it's not
hazard zone which it might be
then what is it finally and this is a
good one but where are the secrets man
at the end of the livestream it was
mentioned that there would be secrets in
this game we know the storytelling is
through seasons and in-game specialists
so are we hunting for mysteries in a
match are we getting megalodon level
events will there finally be a t-rex
[Applause]
i've been to a lot of press conferences
over the years and have to say that the
level of honesty and genuine love of
battlefield stood out to me in this
stream right now it feels like
battlefield's in good hands
we have so much more battlefield 2042
coming up so head on over to gamespot's
youtube page and subscribe to the
channel we're in this together thanks
for watching
[Music]
you